Well, about my guest tonight, he is the Secretary-General of the United Nations.
Please welcome to the program, UN Secretary-General Ban Ki-moon.
It's a great pleasure for me to be participating in this.
I want to make sure that you're comfortable.
I have been traveling to all these hotspots...
...without exception all around the world.
Sometimes, I have to protect myself...
...and I know that you conduct a lot of difficult interviews,...
...meeting with different people.
I'd like to give you this UN peacekeeping helmet to protect yourself.
Keep it handy.
I may need it for my protection.
Is this your way of telling me I'm being shipped out somewhere?
Oh yeah.
That's very kind of you.
You still believe in the idealism that can rise up...
...and snuff out the types of extremism that we've been seeing.
You're still an optimist.
We have to work, and we have to address and we have to be united.
This is unacceptable in the name of humanity.
How can it be so brutal?
How can it be so cruel?
As a human being, we have to address this one.
I'm asking the whole world regardless of political ideology one may have.
We have to unite in the name of humanity.
Well, you would hope that we will soon reach that tipping point...
...and there will be that type of groundswell,...
...and I appreciate you very much for being here.
I know you have a tremendous amount of work to do.
You may keep this.
Thank you very much.
I will keep this.